Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David. It's so long since
I've done one of these. I forgot my
own name. My name is David Flanagan, although
you may know me as Rawkode.
And today, we're taking a look at more
open source cloud native Kubernetes container, all the
cool things technologies.
Today, we're taking a look at Portainer,
and I am joined by cofounder, maintainer, developer,
all the hats, Neil Cresswell. Hey, man. How's
it going?
It's going very good. I'm gonna correct you
though. I'm definitely not a developer.
Oh, no.
Oh, god.
I'm definitely not a developer. I am an
engineer and a consultant, but I'm definitely not
a developer. And to be fair, you don't
want me anywhere near code.
Alright. Well, apologies for that. Maybe you could
give us a little bit of background on
yourself then and correct me at the same
time.
Sure. So, yes, I I am the cofounder
of Portainer.
And I I I built Portainer to solve
a problem that I had a number of
years ago, which was how to make the
transitional jump from someone managing
virtual infrastructure
to someone who now needs to manage container
based infrastructure.
My entire career has been spent in the
infrastructure world.
I was a engineer at IBM. I was
a consultant at IBM. I was consultant at
VMware. I I I lived and breathed, you
know, infrastructure and virtual infrastructure technology.
And seven years ago, v m VMware themselves
opened my eyes to the wonderful power of
Docker, and I'm like, this thing is amazing.
It's an absolute game changer.
But we're going from a very, very mature
and
well
tooled
ecosystem
around virtual infrastructure.
I mean, they they were you know, VMware
had had the tooling nailed for virtual infrastructure
to this new world of of containers.
And, oh my goodness, it was like, we
have just gone back in time,
you know, ten, fifteen years there because we've
you know, it to me, Docker at the
time felt like the early early versions of
of of VMware
ESX
way back in the day. And I'm like,
okay. Let's not try and have this experience
be ten years and leap and and go
from nothing to highly adopted. Let's try and
create a bit of tooling to help people
make that leap, make that jump from being
virtual, you virtual engineers to container engineers.
So I built it for me
predominantly,
and
it's gone nuts.
I I I like to tell a a
story.
We yeah. Anthony, my cofounder, and I, we
we we built this thing. We put it
out there, open source, not knowing what that
meant, of course. So yeah. Because we were
using it internally.
Put it out there.
Somehow, it got picked up on Hacker News.
This was in September.
I woke up on Christmas day six years
ago, and we had a million a million
downloads of the products. And I'm like, wow.
Jeez. What happened there?
New Year's day, ten million downloads.
It
as is the power of of open source,
as is the power of things like Hacker
News' ability to propagate a good story, and
from there, never stopped. I think we're at
3,400,000,000
downloads of the products over over the life
now.
So it's ridiculous.
So there you go. It was a long
winded way of saying hello.
Yeah. Wow. I had no idea just how
quickly the growth was. I mean, I definitely
remember when Portainer was announced. I don't know
if it was the hacker news, maybe it
was a bit longer or a bit shorter
after. I have no idea.
But when I was going to user groups
up and down The UK, it felt like
everybody was running Portainer in their house. They
were running containers using Portainer as the UI.
Like, I imagine it spread pretty much like
wildfire. I mean, 10,000,000 downloads in what space
of a week or two weeks is
that's wild. It's nuts. Yeah. It was nuts.
And at at that stage, was just two
of us and we we seemingly became the
de facto
docker help desk. And so, yeah, our our
our internal communications,
everything else, we we spent so much time
it this was kind of a a side
a side hack. Right? And so we're spending
so much time answering questions because we were
we were spending a lot of time understanding
the technology.
And so we we were able to answer
questions pretty pretty rapid fire, you know, problem
solution, problem solution, problem solution. So
You kind of addressed this, but I'm gonna
ask you and see if can get a
bit more detail. Like, you you said that
the technology containers,
it felt like you were back ten years.
You were used to this very,
I don't know, VMware with lots of tooling
environment where things maybe just worked or were
easier. But was there a specific need that
you were trying to solve with Portainer as
you were adopting containers, you and you and
Anthony? Like, what what was the the the
drive? What pushed you into building this new
tool?
You know, I've I've always described and I
I still describe it to this day because
I don't think much has changed. I mean,
there's more tooling now, but in fact, it's
more complicated in my view because there's now
so many tools to choose from. But I've
always said a Docker host or a Kubernetes
cluster,
it's it's just very raw. Right? A Docker
host is like, in VMware speak, an e
an an ESXi host. A Kubernetes cluster is
like a a
a vSphere cluster.
You would never, in a million years, go
into mission critical production with just just the
bare metal e s s x I host,
and very, very few people would go into
mission critical production with just a VMware cluster.
You would have vCenter around the side to
help you with managing it. You'd you'd have
some some you know, something like Veeam or
some other tooling to give you backups. You'd
have some probably a product like SRM to
give you to give you Doctor replication or
or Doctor failover. You'd have things like like
VMware v v Realize to give you, you
know, insights into your into your your application.
And
one of one of the important things is
is VMware,
you know, recognized very early on having a
bunch of %
disparate tools, each with their own UI,
was not a recipe for success.
And that's why you find inside vCenter, they
added all of the plug ins and they
let you bring everything together. So from within
the vCenter screen,
you could configure things like like your NSX
storage, your vSAN
sorry. Your your NSX networking, your vSAN storage,
all of your observability,
everything else you could do from within the
one tool because they realized that was the
way.
And one of the things I I I
saw in the container ecosystem was,
one, at the time, there was no tooling.
There was just nothing. There was just the
the raw Docker and raw Kubernetes.
Over time, and we still see it now,
you know, go go log in to the
CNCF landscape. There's a bunch of disparate tooling,
but it's disparate tooling. There's no there there's
nothing stitching all that tooling together into a
single
experience that makes it really easy for someone
to jump in and actually manage everything. And,
yeah, my my whole my whole ethos in
life is remove complexity. You know, complexity causes
issues. It just does. And I I hate
complexity with an absolute passion. And so I
I try to remove complexities, and
and I do that by by pulling tooling
together into one place. That's why in Portainer,
you've got GitOps, you've got UI interfacing, you've
got policy engines, you've got everything you can
imagine, because I just hate the idea that
you have to go out into a bunch
of separate disparate tools to achieve what you
should be able to achieve within within one
tool.
Nice.
So would it be fair to summarize that
as Portainer is your single pane of glass
for containers in Kubernetes? Is that your mission?
Is that the goal?
It is. A single pane of glass is
massively overused. I I prefer the I I
prefer the term manager of managers.
So, yeah, we we we like to be
or or to use to use Lord of
the Rings, we wanna be the the the
one tool to rule them all
kind of thing. So we we wanna be
this this one piece of tooling that that
your internal staff have to learn. So so
you learn Portainer. And by the way, Portainer
is very intuitive. There's no need to be
certified in Portainer because you just don't need
to be. It's so intuitive.
And so once once people get get a
taste of Portainer, they don't they don't need
to use anything else. I mean, you could
if you wanted to. We we don't we
don't lock you in. If you wanna go
use other tooling alongside us, feel free. But
what we say is for 80% of of
organizations,
Portainer's native capability is is enough.
Right.
You've already mentioned a bunch of features that
I had no idea existed in Portainer. Like,
you you said get ups. Like, I had
no idea there was that kind of level
to it. And I've seen something on your
blogs that I thought was quite interesting too
about being a management platform for Kubernetes.
But it sounds to me like Portainer has
kind of evolved greatly over the last number
of years.
I'm I'm kind of excited to what we're
gonna see now today because
it could be contained like, container was, you
know, the UI, I see go run this
container for me. It does it and I'm
like, cool. Awesome. But, you know, it it
has evolved a lot then. Right? So you
wanna maybe share a bit more details on
what that's been like for last couple of
years?
You have no idea how hard it is
to to to actually change people's perception of
a brand that's been around a while. I
I genuinely believe it might have been easier
for me to have stopped using the brand
Portainer,
kept kept the same product, simply change change
the name to something else, and and and
we we would have been some some cool
new new application out there on the market.
If you if if you ask people about
about Portainer, they'll almost always respond with what
we were three years ago.
In in the last two years, we've spent
over $10,000,000
re reengineering the product to be this this
Kubernetes,
in fact, universal management platform. So Kubernetes, Docker,
Docker Swarm, of course, Nomad,
any Kubernetes, any cloud, anywhere, laptop, data center,
edge,
anything. You know? It it's this this universal
management tool set that just simply says, if
if you are dealing
in containers,
then Portainer is the tool that you need
to to get your get your applications developed
fast,
into production fast, safe, secure.
That's it. Alright? So, yes, there is there
there there's a GitOps engine built in. There's
basic observability
built in so you can see what your
application's doing. You can see if things are
up or down. You can see see the
events. We make it really, really easy to
discover what's going on in your environment.
One of the big things. Right? If if
you don't know
the commands to type in,
then you can't type in the commands.
So if you don't know Kubernetes can do
something,
then you don't know the command to do
that something, then you're ignorant to the fact
that there is this amazing piece of capability.
Well, Tana makes it blatantly obvious because there's
a button that says show this and you
oh, what's this do? I'll click this. And
now you can you've just you've just discovered
a new piece of native capability
of Kubernetes or Docker. So we make it
really, really easy to to explore what's what's
there.
Yeah.
I'm assuming, and you can correct me if
I'm wrong, but the 10,000,000 that you've invested
did not come from $1 from three of
the five 3,500,000,000 people that downloaded it. So
I'm assuming the
the enterprise
business is is quite successful. The people would
know are taking Portainer and shipping real production
applications.
Is that correct? Like
We are VC backed, so the the the
money comes from from from VC companies who
believe in our vision and believe that there
is a commercial demand
for our Portainer business edition period.
And that's the uptake of that is growing
nicely. So, absolutely, there there is there is
definitely demand for people who want to take
what's available in the free version and expand
on it. You know, we we've expanded a
lot in regards to policy and controls and
and security and governance and all sorts of
things. We've built off the free version and
sell a commercial version
out there for those who want more than
what's in the free version. The free version
is still very feature rich, by the way,
and we've got, you know, roughly 700,000 users
who use the free version every single month.
They log in and do something every single
month. So the the there's a there's a
quite a big loyal global following of the
free version,
but the free version isn't isn't really enough
when when you get beyond one one team
using it. You you want a bit more
governance and control. So that's where the business
edition now comes in. Yeah. That's amazing. That's
awesome. That's exciting to hear as well. Like,
I I speak to a lot of people
that are
struggling with Kubernetes. A lot of people ask
me for advice, they want help. And I'm
actually seeing this trends now where where people
just don't actually want Kubernetes. They want a
platform to run their containers.
And it feels like Portainer should just be
that option that I'm giving to people. It
should be like, there's the UI, there's the
cut off operator to it. So I'm I'm
gonna just let you hand over to the
screen share and show me some awesome things
with Portainer if you're ready to go.
I am. The
it it so you're right. Portainer
Portainer's
goal is to try and make the underlying
technology irrelevant because at the end of the
day, it kind of is irrelevant.
It it kind of is. You actually want
your application live. You know, the the the
the business that employs you as a developer
or the business that employs you as an
ops person or what it you know, whatever
role that that you wanna be in. The
business that employs you doesn't really care about
the tech. That's unless, of course, you Google
or whatever else. Right? But most organizations, they
don't care about the tech. What they want
is a highly available system that delivers
digital applications to market. That's what they care
about. They don't care about the tech. You
know, we as we as techies care about
the tech, but the business doesn't.
But more and more often now, people are
saying, you know what? The tech is actually
causing me headaches. It's a little bit too
complicated for some use cases. I really wanna
try and and divorce myself from the from
as more of the tech as I can.
There's there's, of course, still a subset of
people who just love the tech because the
tech is good fun to play with. That
doesn't necessarily help to help the businesses that
employs them grow. So, you know, we we
we're trying to say for those organizations who
just wanna use the damn thing, Portainer is
right for you. If if you're one of
the one of those organizations or one of
those people who really, really wants to get
in turn every dial, and flick every switch,
Portainer probably isn't for you. So we're we're
we're a bit bit more honest and direct
and clear with our our ideal user.
You know, a a raw a raw expert
who wants to able to flick every dial
and and and and turn every switch is
not
it, you know, Portainer Portainer abstracts away with
the goal of making it really easy to
consume.
Yeah.
I consider myself a bit of an expert.
I also think that I'm so done of
fiddling knobs and and playing with switches. I
mean, I think I just want things to
work now. I don't know if that's just
me getting older or not and
tired perhaps,
but I I
am very salty. I I I have run
I've I've run mission critical cloud services. I
was CEO of a of a public cloud
provider.
One of the worst things to happen is
an outage.
You know, everyone has outages, and anyone who
says that there's they they don't have outages
is lying or hasn't yet had one.
But outages happen
at three in the morning when there's an
outage.
You wanna be able to pick up the
phone and say, who who can get in
here and help me right now? And if
it's one person,
because only one person has the actual depth
of knowledge of the platform, man, you're in
trouble. You you wanna be able to get
to get fifteen, twenty, a hundred people, everyone
in IT wake up and get in here
now. And everyone in there can can roll
up their sleeves and get in there and
try and solve their problem. If if you
have a piece of infrastructure
or a platform that's so complicated, only one
person or two people can support it, man,
you're in trouble. You really are. And,
you know, I I I had that lived
experience. I had this beautiful public cloud, and
I had problems with my my underlying storage
platform.
It was it was beautifully engineered,
but very difficult to triage and troubleshoot. And
so I'm like, man,
you know, once we got out of that
outage, it's like, okay. I need I need
to make this thing way easier. I've gotta
I've gotta take away complexity so that I've
got I've got, you know, more more ready
access to people who can help me triage
and solve problems.
So you you will see you will see
you will see lived lived scars,
blood, sweat, and tears all throughout Portainer because
I've I've I've experienced those. I'm old enough
to have have lived through all of that
pain and suffering, and I'm trying to stop
other people having to live through it too.
Awesome. Alright. We got a a couple of
comments I'll tackle just now. So we got
one from Russell saying, referring back to your
Lord of the Rings quote, but Portainer is
a siren's tool for managing container systems. There
you go.
Cool. And we have a question for our
brilliant guest.
Nicely phrased, Murat. How can I not ask
that question now? But they wanna know about
the future of container platforms and whether maybe
something's going to replace containers. And they mentioned
LXC Podman cat containers. I mean, do you
have any thoughts on what comes next?
Or do you think, you know, those containers
are just perfect?
They're also containers. Yep. But Podman is just,
in speech marks, a fork of Docker. You
know, for for whatever reason, Red Hat decided
that the the direction Docker was taking was
the wrong direction. So they they forked or
the it it's basically built off of Moby,
and it's it's their own thing. So, yeah,
Podman is very, very compatible to Docker. So
it's still the same underlying tech.
They're all based off the same underlying principles.
You know, even even
container d from Kubernetes is it's the same
underlying thing. Now LXC containers are somewhat different.
Containers in general, I think, are are quite
universal. You know, is there gonna be a
new version, a better version, a more secure
version?
% sure. You know, containers today are still
a little bit too wild west if you
ask me.
With it without without a bunch of external
controls,
a container can be used to take complete
complete control of the underlying platform. I'm just
gonna while I've got my screen share up,
I'll show you what I mean here. Yep.
Let me just push that over. There you
go.
So, like, for example, here, you know, in
Portainer, we let you sit some some Docker
security settings here because there are certain things
containers will let you do things
that are actually dumb. They're actually really, really
dumb. Like, for example, I can spin up
a a container that bind mounts the root
file system.
No. That that's a terrible idea. So so
we yeah. In Portainer, we actually let you
say, well, hang on a second. Because Portainer
sits between your users and the underlying infrastructure,
we're we're going to disallow, and we we
basically intercept requests for blind mounts and say,
mm-mm. Not allowed.
Yeah. Like, you you can actually ask a
container
to run-in in the host PID namespace. And
then once you're in the host PID, you
can do anything on the host. That's a
dumb idea. Terrible idea. So block that too.
So that same thing with device maps. You
you can actually you can actually say map
device
slash dev slash h d zero or s
d zero to a container, and then you
can do if there's gonna container and erase
the hard disk. That's a terrible idea.
So the so
yeah. All that stuff, we we basically saying,
mm-mm. We gotta intercept that that and block
it. Now things like Podman
and even Docker rootless mode now can run-in
a way that they don't have root access
to the host. So some of this is
starting to be mitigated, but more and more
often now, I think I think I think
I think we're gonna be crying out for
a more secure version of containers, the next
generation of containers. But
from a end consumer or any user point
of view, I think I think you find
things like serverless containers become more and more
popular. Things like Cloud Run
or the old the older and slightly less
popular Azure ACI,
where you just simply ask the system, here
is my container. Here are the SLAs that
I want you to run this container within.
Go run it for me, and the platform
takes care of it.
I think I think you're gonna see that
kind of thing take off a bit more
where you simply say, hey. I want this
container to deliver
a response times to my to my users
of below x milliseconds.
The system says, okay. I'm I'm seeing a
bit more load. I need to add more
replicas. I'm gonna go ahead and do that.
You you shouldn't have to say, I want
three replicas and turn on auto scaling, and
here are here are the criteria for auto
scaling. The system should know should be able
to determine that from SLAs.
And I think that's that's that's kind of
the future as we as we mature. And
if you look at a Google Cloud Run,
that this is this is a very nice
first version of that.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. I hope that helps, Bharat.
Russell suggested maybe WebAssembly could be a future
technology there. And I think Firecracker falls into
that too. But
we have such an ecosystem, such a community
around containers and so much tooling
that I I think containers have got a
lot of life left at them yet.
Yeah. Wasm at the edge or or wasm
wasm, however you wanna pronounce it. I've I've
got a a crazy Kiwi accent. So,
yeah, wasm at the edge, I think, definitely
has potential. That this whole this whole assembly
on demand, I think, has potential at the
edge.
For some reason, Kubernetes at the edge is
getting a lot of love. Kubernetes at the
edge is very overweight.
You know, it's very hard to to use
Kubernetes at the edge unless you have a
relatively large node. I actually produced a blog
just recently
where I actually benchmarked all of the nano
or micro Kubernetes
distros out there to say, can they run
on a device with one gig of RAM?
The answer is absolutely not. Well, they they
run, but you can't you can't you can't
do anything. The moment you try and it
start even a basic NGINX container,
the whole thing implodes.
So you can't.
Whereas, you know, Docker, Podman, and Nomad are
perfectly adequate. They need need nothing at the
edge. So,
you know, until until much larger hardware
starts to propagate the PLC and the edge
device retailers and know a Raspberry Pi is
not everywhere. So we're talking about, you know,
the the multi billion dollar PLC vendors out
there that we all know that run industry.
Until until the the hardware propagates down to
that level, we're still very, very limited in
resource. And so there's still still a real
focus on how do how do I, as
an operating system, as an operating platform,
use as little resource as possible so there's
more resources for applications.
Sweet. Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
I have very strong opinions on Kubernetes at
the edge just because it's it seems like
we're we're forcing a technology into a use
case where it doesn't doesn't naturally make sense,
but we're trying to trying to tell ourselves
it does.
Yeah. That's actually Anyway Yeah. I mean, we're
seeing I'm assuming I haven't read your blog
post, but I'll find that up. A link
to it to show notes for anyone who's
watching. But I'm assuming the ones you tested
there were like k zeroes and k c
s, and these are the ones that claim
to be kind of edge compatible Kubernetes distributions.
But
Correct. Correct. And yeah. To yeah. A spoiler
alert, they they all need greater than than
mega RAM to to even idle to idle.
So
and
if you've only got a gig of RAM,
700 mega RAM used up just to idle.
In all honesty,
once you get around 900 mega RAM, then
the kernel starts starts blowing up anyway. There's
really no RAM to do anything. So Yeah.
No room to work with the toll. So
you're just
but almost always, they're a single single CPU.
If you're lucky, may maybe a a quad
core, but it's a quad core low throughput
CPU.
One gig of RAM, two gig of RAM,
really.
So it's you're still very limited. Now I
understand that there's the edge edge is a
very large use case. You've got network edge,
which are servers. You've got edge gateways, which
are, you know, far larger I sevens with
eight gig of RAM and mini clusters.
Those ones are fine, but true edge, far
edge, you know, I IoT type use cases,
very, very limited hardware resource.
Alright.
Let's jump over into your your are you
starting with Portainer? Are you doing some slides
first? How are we doing this?
I can do anything. I have I have
some slides
that I can run through if we like.
I literally
just shared these these slides last night. I
built them just for the session.
I can I can run through these things
at a blistering pace and then go and
show you live?
Well, yeah. You failed them. It'd be a
shame not to show them. Come on. It
it would be.
Containers managing containers shouldn't be hard. It
and, unfortunately, it is hard. And anyone who
says it's not hard, either hasn't gone deep
enough yet, it's not fully in production, or
they are absolute ninjas and are able to
comprehend the complexity. But for the average IT
person, managing containers is far harder than it
it it needs to be. And so our
whole ethos is it shouldn't be hard.
Yeah. We we like to to sit in
the middle and be this universal tool set.
We don't care
where you run Kubernetes. If you run Kubernetes
in any of the cloud provider managed managed
Kubernetes offerings, we don't care if you run
Kubernetes on prem. We don't care even if
you don't run Kubernetes and you run Docker
or Podman.
For us, it doesn't matter.
What we care about is helping you get
your container based application into production in a
safe and secure way.
And our whole our ethos is for those
organizations that are just getting started, we wanna
help them.
I I have many times described Portainer
as as a tool that enables the have
nots
to compete with the haves.
And what I mean by that is there
are a bunch of organizations, the have nots,
who who don't have the financial ability to
go and invest in highly skilled
experts
to to support Kubernetes. They don't have the
ability to go and invest, you know, large
sums of money in
in very expensive enterprise products like OpenShift potentially
to to try and offset. So the these
these have these have nots
still need to try and compete against the
much the they're much larger
competitor organizations,
and our goal is to try and enable
them to succeed.
So another way I'd like to describe us
is we are the Robin Hood of cloud
nay of of cloud native.
I like that.
So we describe ourselves as a container management
platform.
And a container management platform
is something that
lets you manage all of these component trees.
They let you manage orchestrator. They they give
the ability to to get observability
of the systems. They let you see the
logs. There's a CICD engine.
They they let you they let you better
better manage the networking service discovery. You know,
all of these things need to be addressed
in some way by the container management platform.
Because like it or not, you actually need
one.
Now you can go and choose to build
one yourself, and this is the CNCF eye
chart.
I think it last time I checked, it
was actually an a one printout. I think
it may even now be an a zero.
So,
you know, you as an engineer or the
company that employs you needs to make a
decision
to go and build a management platform. You
will need one if, you know, if if
you just think that you're gonna go Kubernetes,
Rawkode, Rawkode, you're you're you're solely mistaken. You
absolutely will need a management platform.
Now you will either go and build one
yourself. You'll go and get Argo CD. You'll
you'll probably go and get with your Grafana.
You'll probably go and go and get some
HashiCorp Vault. You're going to get a whole
bunch of these products, and you'll you'll assemble
yourself a management platform.
You've just built yourself an ongoing maintenance nightmare.
Now now you need to make sure that
all of these products well, for a start,
you need to need to make sure the
products that you've that you've chosen actually have
life in them. So they've been actively developed.
They're they're well funded. They're they're not they're
not gonna vanish tomorrow because you're gonna have
to replace them. But then you need to
sure that they are interoperable with each other,
that they're in that they're inter interoperable with
the version of Kubernetes or Docker that you're
running,
and you have to maintain and and patch
them as a case of unit. You have
now created
a a maintenance overhead to manage this platform.
So you can do that or you can
choose Portainer. That's kinda where we're at with
this thing.
You know, why skilled labor shortages? You know,
if if you go look at any CNCF
survey,
what are the barriers to adoption? It's pretty
much these six.
It's very hard to find people.
When you do find them, they're they're eye
watering and expensive.
It takes a long time for people to
to come up to speed
with with containers in general.
Things like Kubernetes,
they're not secure. I'm not gonna use the
term insecure by default because that that has
negative connotations, but they are not secured by
default. They expect you to know what you're
doing to secure them. You have to go
in and and lock them down.
They're not locked by default. You have lock
them down. If you don't know what you're
doing, platform's insecure. There was
there there's so many examples
or or surveys that have been taken where
completely open Kubernetes clusters are exposed to the
Internet because people just didn't realize they have
to lock it down.
Things like like Kubernetes are back. It's pretty
easy
to actually configure users and roles for one
cluster. You can you can go and manually
correct users. You can go and manually create
roles and role bindings, But that's one cluster.
When you got 20 clusters or 30 clusters
or 200 clusters,
oh my god. To do that across that,
now now
now they need a tool like Okta or
something else to try and take care of
all of the federated user identity and and
how you can do all the RBAC management.
So it's tricky. Data operations, again, if you
don't know the commands to go and to
go and triage the the view the events,
you know,
you know, you you really are struggling, so
we wanna try to make that easier.
And, yeah, providing secure access to the environment,
you know, a lot of people say the
the only the only safe way to give
a developer access to Kubernetes is to not
give a developer access to Kubernetes.
Really?
How how then are they supposed to triage
their application in production? Really, you wanna give
them secure access. Now the reason a lot
of people don't give dev access is because
it's actually quite hard to go and configure
the roles and role bonding successfully so that
they don't have don't have accidental too many
rights. So
they're they're they're just main six reasons.
We
have three now I've called them product variants,
but you could actually think of these as
use cases. It's actually the same product. They're
just different different use cases.
So Portainer,
it it being used as a universal management
platform. If you have the need to to
manage Docker on your local machine, maybe you've
got some Docker swarm because you've got some
legacy environments or or whatever.
You've got some Kubernetes. Maybe you've got some
Nomad. The Portainer,
as a single platform, can do all of
that.
Maybe you're all in on Kubernetes, but you
want you want a way to centrally manage
Kubernetes. No problem. We can do that for
you as well.
Or may maybe maybe you're actually got a
really large edge use case,
I IoT
or IoT type use case, network edge, call
it what you like, smart city. Portainer is
very, very strong in the edge management as
well. So we have three distinct use cases.
We're calling in three three different variants of
the product. It's the same product under the
cover, so you don't you don't you don't
choose one and then then you're locked in.
It's the same base product. But
and, again, at a nutshell, the main the
main benefit of Portainer is to facilitate the
the transition from VMware or VMs
into containers. We help you or help your
team with that that mental transition
by giving familiar tooling, you know, that's a
familiar experience.
We make it really easy to see what's
possible with with the tech. It's very easy
to discover capability because there's a button that
does something, and you're like, oh, what's this
button do? And so you now realize that
there's actually some underlying capability that's amazing.
And
the the time to learn Portainer
is very, very, very short. I was talking
to to to somebody just recently who said
they spent two weeks looking at one of
our competitor products and hadn't really got it
working. And he said within five minutes, had
Portainer up and running, integrated with his active
directory. He'd configured a couple of classes, and
he had RBAC running. I was like, yeah.
That's pretty cool. That's what we wanna do.
So, you know, we we want once once
you get going real quickly.
So get get you going fast. You know,
Kubernetes, multi cluster management, really simple. No lock
in. Yeah. Portainer just works with any Kubernetes
API.
We help you secure the environment through through
policies and controls. We make it really easy
to triage, and it's very easy to drive
Portainer.
Edge,
massive scale. You know, a a single instance
of Portainer can actually manage 45,000
remote environments,
and we are scaling that.
The target is a hundred thousand by sort
of middle of next year, and we're gonna
keep scaling beyond that. So you can actually
add,
you know, a lot of clusters or a
lot of individual nodes
because we we develop Portainer to be easy
to understand.
OT engineers,
which, you know, systems engineers in industry,
It's easy for them to understand.
We have things like device management as well.
We've got integrations with Intel,
AMT for lights out. That's like a a
BMC card for server people.
Zero touch device onboarding.
Portainer is self hosted, so we can run
safely behind your firewall. You don't have to
give the keys to your kingdom to some
SaaS service. It's all inside your firewall.
Portainer needs about 20 mega memory to run,
so it's really efficient. So, naturally, it works
well in an edge.
And we
have a lot of async
controls,
you know, API controls, so we actually work
really well over networks that are highly latent
or unreliable.
And our goal is basically to make things
really, really easy.
Really easy.
You don't have to try and remember all
of the command line. You don't have to
try and know how to write YAML. Mean,
if you wanna write YAML, go ahead. We
can we can help you do that with
that GitOps engine. But if you don't want
to, you don't have to. I'm always on
the UI.
Yep. There's a there's a there's a UI
that that will do it all for you.
Makes it nice and easy.
G two says we're awesome. And so because
g two says we're awesome, I say we're
awesome.
G g two, unlike Gartner, is actually something
that's done by the community. So the community
votes
and ranks it rather than
a
independent company like like Gartner, basically saying you
are where you are. G two is actually
is actually crowdsourced,
and people go and actually submit votes and
comments and vote for who they believe and
where they should be. So this is actually
direct feedback from our users.
We are really the only tool that
spans every cloud provider,
every Kubernetes,
Docker, serverless even. So, you know, we're if
you have a very hybrid world, we're the
only tool of choice for that. And and
we're really the only tool that can go
from
from data center to edge to my laptop
to cloud, any cloud. So it's very, flexible
in that regards.
Portainer sits in between your users and the
platform.
So when you when you deploy Portainer,
users interface with Portainer. They don't interface with
the underlying platform anymore. So it's very good
because it means that you don't have to
expose your Kubernetes APIs
externally.
Portainer
takes over
and is the API endpoint for your users
to interface with. So if they're using third
party tools, maybe like OpenLens or KubeCTL
or the the Azure
I mean, the
the Azure DevOps tooling or anything like that
that wants to talk to an API, it
could talk to Portainer, and Portainer will proxy
that to the back end based on relevant
permissions.
That means that you can really lock down
API access to your clusters in the back
end.
So we sit in between. We take care
of all of the user authentication.
We we basically,
you know, provide a safety blanket around all
all of the environments to make sure that
users can't do dumb things.
We we make it really easy to do
to do hard things, and we make it
very hard to do dangerous things.
Portainer's
set self hosted, can run multiple things, connect
it to your auth. We support
OAuth and LDAP, so you can go to
any kind of OAuth provider.
SSO
is
built into the product even in the free
version. We don't believe in in a SSO
tax. So SSO is available.
Roles and teams are back in native proxy.
And, again, Portainer sits in between everybody
and connects through to agents that run-in remote
environments. So really, really flexible tooling.
And I'm not gonna go anymore on slides.
I'm gonna actually show you the thing.
Awesome.
Great. Any questions come up through that?
No. I think that was very informative. I
had no idea that you actually processed the
Kubernetes API, and I could still leverage kind
of my, you know, standard tooling. So that
was a nice little treat.
So now I'm just looking forward to actually
seeing the demo and the UI and what
we can actually do with it.
We got a comment from Eddie just saying,
hey.
And saying great t shirt. Although,
we've spoken about the complexity of Kubernetes so
much, I may have to hide my Kubernetes
t shirt. I don't know.
Right. Yeah. I'm just jumping the command line,
but I'll stop doing that at this point
in time.
So, yes, we do. You see when when
you log in I'm I'm logged in as
an admin, and you wouldn't normally log in
as an admin. So you're seeing more of
the UI than you would do, and I
could probably log in as a user to
show you, but for in in the interest
of time, it won't for now.
But here, I've got a bunch of Kubernetes
environments.
And if I click kube config,
I can go and generate a kube config
file that will allow me to connect to
all of these environments. And if I download
that file
and open it,
you'll see here all of the Kubernetes endpoints
are actually Portainer.
So they're all connecting through. So no matter
which cluster I'm talking to, I'm actually talking
through. So here, I've got a line node,
I've got a CVO, I've got a GKE,
I've got a DigitalOcean, I've got an AKS.
All of them, you're actually connecting through to
Portainer as the API proxy.
So from
kubectl on my machine or OpenLens on my
or whatever are the tooling you choose to
use on your local machine,
then you can you can connect to these
back end clusters through Portainer, and we we
basically just get in the middle and and
make sure that the RBAC roles are applied
and everything's working just fine. So
in that regard, it's nice and easy.
So if I come into a cluster, as
an example, I'll come into a DigitalOcean cluster.
We
have the ability again, I'm an admin. Right?
So I have I have god mode access
to this environment. I have the ability to
create namespaces
for in here. I can actually say, I
wanna create them from a manifest so I
can link this back to a Git repo
and have a Git repo, you know, a
GitOps engine that, you know, controlling the net
the namespace.
Or if I don't want to, I can
use our form. And from the form, you
can go and things set things like like
quotas for the namespace. So can say, okay.
This namespace has this kind of quota.
I wanna actually say there's a load balance
of quota. They can only actually spin up
a request through load balances
in here. So that, you know because load
balances are expensive. I I look at our
our cloud bill every month and a huge
portion of it goes go goes on load
balances. So maybe just maybe you wanna control
that. Do we want people to be able
to use the ingress controller? If so,
what what what domain names are allowed? So
we might wanna say, okay. You can only
use this these domain names.
Are there any registries that we wanna give
them access to and we'll propagate the registry
credentials?
Do we want them to actually have access
to persistent persistent storage? If so, how much
persistent storage can they assign? So we can
go and set all of these things, or
we can just do a raw one and
say, you know what? There's there's actually nothing.
No no restrictions. We're gonna create a really,
really simple namespace.
And off we go, you go and create
it.
Once you have a namespace, you can actually
see, well, who has access to the namespace?
So you can see, well, you know, who
which which teams, which users,
or which teams have access to that namespace.
So it makes it nice and easy to
grant access to it.
And, again, coming back to us trying to
be a bit of a guardrail
at a cluster level, we can actually say,
you know what? We don't want our people
to have access to the the default namespace.
Yes. So many people can, yeah, continue to
use the default namespace. Don't use the default
namespace.
If when you when you are deploying applications,
put the application in a namespace. Don't use
the default namespace. It's just dumb. So we
actually say, you know what? As an admin,
we're actually gonna flick a switch, and then
no one can use the default namespace. It's
just blocked. If they try to deploy into
it, we'll say, uh-uh. Not allowed.
So that is very good practice and something
that we strongly recommend.
We even do things like you know, Kubernetes,
because of its infinite flexibility,
it doesn't wanna say no to anything.
So you can have a a a Kubernetes
cluster running on three Raspberry PIs,
and then
a user can ask that cluster, hey. I
wanna deploy an application. I want that I
want that application to have a gig of
RAM
or 256
gig of RAM.
And Kubernetes will say, okay.
And then in the background, it'll go and
fail because the because, you know, a Raspberry
Pi cluster doesn't have 256
gig of RAM. So it'll just fail. It'll
sit there in in a in a crash
back loop because there's no there's no resource.
And the reason Kubernetes lets you do that
is because it says, well, if you have
auto scaling enabled here, like,
your node auto scaling,
right now, you might not have enough resource.
But thirty seconds from now, when more nodes
have been added to the cluster, you might.
So what we'll do is say, fail now,
but we'll but we'll keep retrying in case
in case you actually add more nodes.
If you don't use node auto scaling,
then your ability to over to to ever
service requests that are beyond the cluster's capability
is zero. So we actually let you flick
a switch to say, don't let users ask
for things that that the cluster in its
current state can deliver.
Again, we're just trying to make it substantially
easier
for for users. So you users don't do
things that then immediately fail and, like, well,
it succeeded, and now it's failing. What's going
wrong? So they they're they're going immediately wasting
time triaging
when, really, they shouldn't be wasting time triaging.
We should just stop them doing things that's
gonna immediately fail because because the cluster isn't
equipped to deliver it. Same thing like load
balances.
It doesn't in Kubernetes, you you you can
ask your micro case cluster or whatever else.
Hey. I want an application, and the application
needs to be published with service type load
balancer.
You have no load balancer. It'll sit pending
forever. Well, it's just dumb. It's gonna go
back you're gonna go to triage mode. So
we can say, don't use a load balancer.
And then if a user asks for a
load balancer, we won't we won't let them
actually submit the request. We all say, this
this this cluster has has no load balances.
Choose another service type, ingress or something else.
So, again, we're we're trying to stop people
doing things that we know will immediately fail.
Does that make sense? It does did.
Yeah. We're just it's just trying to trying
to trying to save time. Again, there's nothing
worse than saying yes and then failing immediately,
and the user has to go into triage
mode. It's just that's just crazy.
But, also, things like like
like constraints here. If you turn on pod
pod constraints, we will we will go and
we will go and deploy automatically in the
cluster for you, things like o like, OPA
gatekeeper.
And here, we're setting OPA policies
to restrict what users can do in in
the cluster.
Again, trying to stop users doing dangerous things.
So you you don't have to have OPA
with but when you when you flip the
switch and click okay, we'll go and deploy
the o p the OPA gatekeeper service for
you and configure all these rules for you
automatically.
So, again, we're just trying to make it
trying to make it really, really quick and
easy to do to do relatively complicated things.
Like, if anyone's configured, they'll be a gatekeeper.
It's not easy. So
we we try and do this for you.
Yeah. I'm just glad you have the toggle
button so I don't have to remember how
to write RIGO because
I'm terrible at writing RIGO.
Yeah. We we likely will provide you the
ability to upload a a YAML file if
you already have one that will basically, you
know, answer boxes for you, you know, like,
boxes for you.
Because one of the things that we've been
criticized of is that we're we're not not
asterisk as code enough.
So we we will we will provide the
ability to to leverage code in the future.
So somebody really really wants to write YAML
to configure Portainer. They can configure Portainer with
YAML.
Correct. So we we we will we will
be iterating that capability
in the future and more and more,
you know, things in Portainer are gonna gonna
start getting a a YAML
ability rather than click to enable. But at
the moment, we're we're trying to make things
so so crazy simple. And the way to
make it crazy simple is tick boxes or
or or switches.
Okay. And we have a a couple of
questions if you're happy to tackle them just
now. Got it. So Russell was asking if
there is a Portainer managed service or whether
they run it themselves.
There is not. Everything is run yourself.
If there is enough demand for a managed
service, then I then I would consider it.
Never never say never to a commercial opportunity.
There is not currently a managed service primarily
because we don't believe there needs to be.
Portainer is so easy to use and so
lightweight
that we don't believe that there there needs
to be a managed service, but happy to
happy to offer one if there's enough demand
for one.
Alright. And, Russell, following up with the second
question and was asking, is there a way
to filter all resources attached to an application?
So, like, if we have a a pod,
can we see that there's a namespace attached,
some storage attached,
network policies, and all that?
So if if we come into an application,
for example,
and I choose one, this test one, you
can come in here and you can see
here's the pod.
If there's persistence, you can see that there's
persistence. You can see there's any configurations.
You can see there's always scaling. Could you
submit little bit on that page?
Sure. I forget that I have a terrible
font size. Is that better?
I will I'll deploy one. Right? So if
I do NGINX,
and it's just a simple NGINX image,
I am going to have an environment variable
of foo and bars. It's not gonna do
anything. I'm going to persist
slash data.
It's gonna be
10 gig in size, and it's gonna come
from this DO block storage.
I am going to have one instance. I
could turn on auto scaling if I wanted.
I'm going to publish it as a load
balancer
for 80
and deploy. So you can see here, we're
gonna create a service of type the name
engine x of type load balance. We're gonna
create a service called this of type cluster
IP. We're gonna create a stateful set called
engine x. This is what we're doing behind
the scenes for you. You don't you don't
know or care that we've done that, but
that's what we've done for you. And deploy.
It's gonna deploy, and this is gonna go
and ask DigitalOcean
to give me a load balance. So it's
gonna go and ask DigitalOcean to give me
some persistent volume.
And now if I come into this application,
you'll see here that
you can access this through the cluster IP.
You can access it through the load balancer.
You know, the XML IP is still pending,
we gotta wait for DigitalOcean to deliver it.
You can see here here's the configuration. You
can see here here's the data persistence,
the container name, the pod name, system folder,
and here is the the the back the
the back end volume. So we've automatically created
the PVC for you
and assigned it.
It's gonna wait to be scaled up. Eventually,
you can see the logs. You can go
and see all of the metrics information
for it. Now
I'll come back and get one that is
actually already up.
Oh, it's actually already up.
Well, I should've just refreshed. I'm just impatient.
So you can see here, you can already
see the stats. So this is now talking
to the Kubernetes metric server and pulling in
metrics around this application. So it's not doing
anything, obviously, because it's just a dummy genetics
container. But,
yeah, this this is talking to metrics and
pulling in some metrics.
We can actually come back here and see
the application. I can go and get the
logs for the application in one place,
which does make it easy.
And if I need to, I can get
a console into that into that pod and
triage
that pod if I need to as well.
So you're actually in and doing things.
So it makes it nice and nice and
easy to interface with it. So I don't
know if that's
answering the question.
So here, we're still waiting.
No. Okay. Anyway, we're still waiting for it.
So it's pulled the image. It's scaling.
You can also see the YAML, by the
way, if you if you care enough about
it.
I think that's question.
We we can see all the kind of
attached resources.
Is there any special record sorry. Is there
any visual representation,
you know, like a graph, main map, and
if like that? That could be a cool
feature.
Absolutely.
No. But it's a good feature.
By the way, if you come to the
namespaces, click on the namespace.
You can actually see the applications running within
the namespace as well.
Or if you want another view, you can
come to the cluster,
and you can click on the nodes of
the cluster if you wanted to, and you
can see the applications that are running on
that on that node as well. So there's
a whole bunch of differing differing views if
you want to to look at it as
well.
K. And, again, from the cluster, you can
see things, you know, with, you know, the
memory reservation, memory use, CPU. You can see
the node stats as well, and, again, talking
to metric server. So it it's a very
deep experience. It really is a very deep
experience.
Again, the volumes so you can see here
the
that this is the the the claim that
we've created here against the block storage. So
here we are here up and running.
So it does make it easy. And, if
you if you really, really want to, you
can click the kubectl shell and you can
you're actually in that cluster. Kubectl
get nodes.
You're actually in that cluster
inside Portainer directly engaging with that cluster should
you want to actually use the command line
because there's something you wanna do that's that's
beyond what's available in the UI, should you
need to.
Cool.
So pretty pretty easy to to go and
configure, you know, like, to go and configure
a stateful set with a load balancer and
a config and and and and and, you
know, that that manifest that that helm file
would be quite large.
I I actually deployed that in a very,
very short amount of time. Now is this
is this infrastructure as code? No.
Would you would you would you do this
in production? Probably not. But for a dev
who wants to experiment on their machine or
a dev who just needs quickly spin things
up in a dev cluster, nothing wrong with
the UI to get things done quickly. In
production, obviously,
you would create
a a a manifest file and you'd use
things like like a GitOps engine, you configure
automatic updates. So you're gonna poll Git, look
for changes, and force redeploy any changes in
the cluster.
So, you know, you in production, you'd use
GitOps. But outside of production, ain't nothing wrong
with a good old fashioned UI saving you
time.
Argue argue against that. Go on.
No. I'm not arguing about it. I think
I
I think we definitely need more simplicity in
this in this space. Like, things are wildly
complicated.
It just. Absolutely.
It it I mean I mean, how how
long would it take you to go to
to go write a a manifest from scratch?
In fact, I can I can show you
the manifest? Right? So,
yeah, how long would it take you to
go go and write a manifest from scratch
that that does all the stuff? And the
unless you're an absolute wizard or or you're
starting from one that you already have and
you're just simply copying a manifest and and
modifying a couple of things.
And, you know,
you really you really gotta gotta be a
a pretty pretty special you know, oh, here
you go. The load balance is already up.
So there you go. We've got the IP
address from DigitalOcean and and NGINX is up
and running.
So Cool.
And as you'd expect, if you delete the
application,
we go and clean up after ourselves. If
you remove it,
we'll we'll go and tell DigitalOcean,
go and go and delete the volume, go
go and delete the load balancer, and it'll
go and clean up after itself as well.
So,
yeah, it's all all legit here.
Alright. You ready for the hard question?
Go on.
Does Portainer provide any convenience around custom resources?
CRDs,
not yet.
So if you are installing
operators,
you can install them using Helm charts.
But, no, we don't currently have any native
support for CRDs.
Little honestly, though, most CRDs are either available
as a manifest that you can install, just
add add add application,
create for manifest, and even paste in
a operator
YAML if you need to. Yeah. What I
was thinking was, like, I wonder if you
know, because once you apply the CRD to
the cluster, you have those open API spec
available over the API. It's, a Portainer could
consume that and then get me a web
form for those fields based on the open
API spec. That would be a pretty cool
feature.
Not yet, but happy happy to take that.
Failing what I should.
Happy happy to take a feature request. Absolutely.
Any any
anything that actually makes it easier to consume?
Absolutely. It's really funny. Like, we we we
added Helm support push push Helm support out.
And, yeah, Helm Helm is is is a
very cool tool. Right? You know, it makes
it very easy to deploy stuff, but you
still need to know how to modify the
values dot YAML file. So we make we
make it really easy to edit values dot
YAML directly inside Portainer so you can you
can, you know, edit it directly and deploy.
It's really funny. We actually really we we
we actually released this feature, and then we
got commentary back.
Why why are you actually releasing features for
Helm? Helm's dead. It's now all about all
about customized. So, like, what?
It's like this that this thing that this
this this environment changes so quickly. So anyway,
the Helm is not dead. Helm is definitely
not dead. Helm
is so easy.
So yeah. So you you you can see
here's here's the the values file. You can
make changes to to the values file, hit
hit deploy, and we'll go and deploy it
in into the cluster. So it makes it
really, really easy to work with Helm as
well.
You can head add other other Helm repos
should you should you need to.
So it makes it nice and nice and
easy.
So
you're logged in to Portainer right now. What
what
sign on mechanism is used for this instance
that we're looking at today?
This one, if I go to settings
authentication,
is using local or internal just because it's
my demo environment,
but there's absolutely nothing. And by the way,
you can change your password
characters if you want. We got some we
got some beat ups for trying to enforce
good practices for passwords. So we made we
we made it fixable because some
people wanna pass with length of one characters.
In fact, some people wanna pass with length
of zero.
So that that this one uses internal.
In in all honesty, in production, I would
strongly recommend something like OAuth. Yeah. Because if
you if you do OAuth, you've got things
like single sign on that you can do
automatic user provisioning, automatic team mapping. So if
users are in a team or sorry, in
a group in OAuth, we will we will
automatically associate them to a team inside Portainer.
So it makes it really easy for management.
You don't you don't manage users in Portainer
or Teams at that point anymore. It's all
managed upstream.
So in all honesty, you'd you would use
one of these primary providers, and it's pretty
easy to go configure against the primary providers
in this regard.
So I probably should change my devo to
actually use to use something a bit more
reliable.
Alright. No worries.
We we have things like authentication logs so
you can see who has tried to log
in to the environment. And when they have
logged in, what have they done? So, you
know, this isn't a audit log. There's no
delete button. There's no purge. We keep this
log for seven days and cycle it.
So, you know, your your c a your
CISO can log in and see who caused
the outage at two in the morning and
what do they do. So you come in
here and inspect the payload and see what
was what was sent to the back end
cluster.
So that's sits here in a really nice,
yeah, audited audible way. This is the paid
version I'm using, by the way, not the
free version. So there's a few more features
in here.
Registries,
providing access to registries
is quite
quite quite a burden. So we let the
administrator define registries here
so you can add a registry. And once
you add registries in here, you can come
into a cluster and say, I want to
enable this cluster
to to use this registry.
And then want these users in this cluster
or this namespace to have access to it,
and then we'll we'll actually propagate the image
pull secret into the namespace automatically for you.
So your so your dev users don't need
to worry about it.
So makes it nice and easy to to
work with with private registries. And if you
so desire it, because we're getting a of
people ask for it, you can actually hide
access to Docker Hub. So we actually hide
it from the UI so people can't see
the public Docker Hub registry.
So just a lot of lot of really
interesting features there.
We have another question for Russell
who is asking,
is there anything like alerting?
Or do would you expect people to manage
them through other tools?
I'm assuming that being if a pod is
crashing back off, and is there a way
to kind of alert that for someone?
So we we make it obvious
in the UI. So in the UI, we
make it obvious that it's it's failing. Like,
you can see here, this is this is
healthy.
If if there is a zero of one,
this goes bright red
to show you that there's a problem. That's
not alerting, but that's making it that that
there's a visual cue.
By the way, this green dot here is
if you are using an image.
So the green means the image that is
running is the same version as the image
that's in the registry.
If if they differ, this little green dot
goes red
just as a as a complete tangent there.
So there's no native alerting per se in
Portainer, but what we are actually doing is
integrating with a product called SOSIVO,
s o s I v dot I o.
So Portainer is building or has built and
will be releasing
imminently
in a in a native integration with Sausavo.
And when you
inside a cluster, you will be able to
turn on Sausavo monitoring.
We will deploy the Sausavo collectors.
In fact, if you noticed, there's probably a
nice space called Salsavo in here because I've
been playing around with it.
You can actually turn on Salsavo alerting, and
it'll it does all of that really cool
stuff. Salsavo is
what Prometheus and Grafana should be.
The the re the reason reason why we've
decided to partner with Sausavo is they share
a very similar ethos to us.
If you have a wall of metrics from
Prometheus and Grafana,
unless you know what you're looking at, the
metrics are relatively meaningless.
Salsavo
ingest the metrics, has a has a whole
rules engine inside it, and says this means
that. So rather than just giving a wall
of metrics that says, hey. There's a problem
with the cluster. This is the problem, and
this is what you should do to fix
it.
So I I kinda really like that
that, you know, ease of access to true
observability.
You can still see the raw data if
you want, but but they they they spend
a lot of time building the front end.
And so we're we're gonna pull all of
that information into Portainer and that you see
it, but also you can see the alerts.
So right now, you can't, but
so serve.io.
These guys. By the way, absolutely no commercial
relationship with these guys at all. Just like
their product and wanna integrate with them.
So pretty cool.
So no. No. No native alerting. But once
we have the source of our integration, we
will be able to do that. Yes.
Alright. Cool. Other quick other questions? What's the
custom templates thing? Did we look at that?
Custom templates are awesome.
And in fact, I probably should've talked about
them sooner. So Portainer's
goal is to enable those who need to
be enabled.
So even inside an organization. Right? So let
let let's let's say that you're you're a
company, and the company has a luxury of
being able to hire one person who knows
about Kubernetes.
That one person can actually go and set
up a bunch of stuff
for the
the the less empowered members of their team.
I'm I'm I'm choosing my words carefully here.
And so a an expert
user could come in here and say, I'm
actually going to go and create a bunch
of templates,
which could be they're they're all manifest based.
It could be you you you might paste
in a manifest that that defines an ingress.
You might define you might paste in a
manifest that deploys an application with a whole
bunch of Bushtash variables. You can you can
you can basically add manifest in here and
save them as a template that then other
users can go and consume, click deploy, click
deploy, click deploy.
So it's it's a very, very simple and
easy way to consume advanced capability that an
expert inside your organization has created for you.
So really, really, really, really nice way to
to share things.
Similar similar concept, by the way, with the
namespaces when I said the
ingress controllers. Right? You may say, you know,
the expert person will say, I'm actually we
we only only own the domain, you know,
testtestdomain.com.
So I'm gonna only allow users to request
that. And so once this is done,
when users
inside the namespace go to create a service
of type
ingress,
the only drop down are the domains that
the expert has pre preauthorized or pre validated.
So a a user can't go and create
some random domain and and push it out.
So we
we we we try to make it really
easy. So, again, custom templates are a way
to share things. And so as as a
user,
I can actually go and deploy this. So
I can I can come into this this
one here, and I can see, for example,
I've got a bunch of stuff in here?
This is this is a PVC claim, deploys
an engine x. So there's a bunch of
things in here,
and I can go and deploy the thing
from here pretty pretty quick and easy.
Cool.
So it's just it's just shared.
So does that make sense?
Yeah. It does make sense. Definitely.
Especially for those things where, you know, people
like to think that Kubernetes deployments are unicorns
and super unique. But actually, deploying most applications
to Kubernetes can be templated relatively easily. Like,
we all just need to specify a container
image at a port and maybe some, like,
CPU limits. Like, nothing really is that special
or unique.
Yeah. Especially when you're using using
using variables. So in inside the variable, you
can actually put in
just basic Bushtask variables. And then, basically, when
when you go to deploy, you can that,
you know, you there's a nice input box
here, and you can actually replace the the
the variables at deploy time. So it makes
them able to be to be reused in
a really, really simple way. So it's just
it's just a nice easy way to say,
you know, I've I've I want expert in
my team. I'm one I'm one person. I
can only work seventy hours in the day.
I I I I need to I need
to make myself infinitely more
efficient or effective
by propagating my knowledge through to other members
of my team through things like templates,
And that that's kind of the goal. So
even though I said Portainer is a tool
that almost always an expert might shy away
from,
an actual true expert, a true expert realizes
the the the infinite time savings that's gonna
make
and say, actually, you know what? I'm sick
of getting dumb questions from my my my
my colleagues.
I'm gonna put Portainer in here and actually
provide provide a means to abstract away
stuff that I get asked all the time
as base templates. So
at your exit, I say, you know what?
This is actually really, really interesting. I can
now I can now get back five hours
of my day. I'm not answering dumb questions,
building building templated manifests.
Cool.
Are there any other features you want? Sorry.
Let me go. No. One one of the
most important things is dark mode. Everyone wants
dark mode, if I don't click it if
if someone will ask, is there a dark
mode? Yes. It's dark mode. I I prefer
light mode, but there is a dark mode.
There's also a high con high contrast mode
for visually impaired, but
you can choose to this. So we have
API tokens. If you have automation, external automation,
you can add API tokens, and then you
can automate Portainer.
By the way, we're an API first product.
Everything in the front end has an API,
and you can you can control it through
API.
Very cool.
Yeah. It's weird how we went through this
phase where, like,
biggest complaint people had about any better software
was it didn't have dark mode yet. And
it's like
I just see that for every like, even
random products that were just it's just why
is that your complaint? Like, it just makes
no sense.
That's just where we are now.
It is.
We we haven't talked about Edge and I
I probably won't in any depth, but Edge
lets us manage Edge devices.
Edge devices are simply devices out there on
the public Internet or out there across the
other end of a very, very slow WAN
connection. Call it what you like. They're devices
that are not that are not in the
data center. In fact, they're very far away
from the data center.
We have the ability to group them so
we can group them based on whatever
makes sense for you, either manual grouping or
dynamic grouping.
And then you can go and deploy
a manifest
or a Nomad job or a composed file
against a group,
and Portainer will then go and say, hey.
All of the devices in that group, go
and run this application and make sure it
make sure it stays running. So it's a
way to do to actually say, take this
application, go and deploy it a thousand times,
10,000 times, whatever you want to all these
devices,
go do it. And if it fails, tell
me.
But, basically, just keep trying until it works.
So it's a really nice way to essentially
manage the deployment of applications on mass.
You can also run edge jobs, which lets
you run commands on the remote node directly.
So you could do things like, you know,
d f and pull in pull in anything
you like to it. So you can go
run things on remote devices, and they're basically
just just batch scripts that run.
I guess I could choose that if I
had, like, the Kubernetes clusters, one in Asia,
1 in Europe, 1 in The US, and
I want you to replicate all the workloads
across them, would I use
%. You could use it for that. Yeah.
%. And I know it's not really as
you say.
Still, I think a use case I would
have at least.
%.
Right right now, we're the feature is called
Edge. It it really should just be called
multi cluster management or multi device management. But
right now, it's just Edge stacks just just
because it makes sense. Yeah.
So, yeah, it's a it it it's it's
a very, very powerful tool, and I can
spend days going through every feature because we've
we've built something that is just monster.
There's so many so many features, so many
capabilities of the product. It's near limitless in
its power.
You know, I I am I am near
near useless in front of a kubectl command
prompt. I just don't know how to do
anything because I don't need to. I just
do everything in Portainer. I've forgotten all the
commands. But you could you could set me
any kind of challenge. You could say, hey,
Neil. Go go deploy this application like this,
and I'll I'll be able to do it
in Portainer. There's very, very few
examples where I couldn't do something using Portainer,
and and I'll be forced to go back
to to a command line.
Sweet.
Alright.
Are we done with the demo? Is there
anything else you would like to show before
we finish up?
No. We can stop there.
Alright. Yeah. There was a lot to cover
there. I I like the simplicity
that Portainer brings to Kubernetes clusters, but even
more special than that is that it's not
restricted to Kubernetes clusters. You know, we we
don't play with Nomad, we've seen the option
pop up a few times. There was Docker
Compose stuff.
It's like Portainer as a management interface for
kind of universal containers. And I I I
like that approach. I think it's gonna empower
and enable
many many people as I'm sure already as
you said what? There's like over 700,000
active users or something like that. So Every
month.
That is a staggering number, but it's very
good to see.
So we got a couple of sorry. On
you go.
Let's say we we we definitely see people
who are are net new to containers
making a start with Docker and then over
time transitioning to Kubernetes.
And so we we really do help them
with that process. You know, they they can
they can learn how to use it, learn
about microservices,
learn learn about triaging microservices in Portainer. And
then when they're ready,
then they they we we're with them as
as I make the jump to Kubernetes.
A lot of the other tooling out there
is only Kubernetes,
and you have no choice to go from
zero to a thousand with you know, in
the site. If if you're not ready,
good luck to you. You got you got
you got some some serious, you know, headwinds
ahead of you, whereas Portainer really tries to
say, well, actually, you know what? We can
we can actually crawl before we walk before
we run. We we're kinda, you know, guiding
people on what what I've determined a relatively
sense sensible progression from no knowledge to advanced
knowledge.
Awesome. A noble and good mission.
We have some thank yous in the chat.
So Russell and Morat both say thank you.
Really nice demo, and thank you again. So
I will echo their statements. Thank you, Neil,
for joining us, for guiding us through Portainer.
Before we finish, do you wanna is there
anything you can share about Portainer's roadmap? Anything
you're stated about for the next three to
six months? Anything you wanna share with our
audience before we finish up?
We just launched a new website. Go have
a look at it. It is lean, mean,
and clean. Inside
there, we have a home and student offer.
So right now, if you're not aware, we
have Portainer CE, the open source version. We
have Portainer Business, the closed source licensed version.
We make our closed source
biz the the closed source version available for
free
for anyone who has under five nodes in
their cluster. Right? So anyone with under five
nodes can go and get a license for
for Portainer business right now and use it,
and I would strongly recommend if you have
under five nodes, use that version rather than
CE version. You get a lot more capability.
If you are a home user or student
user and you have more than five nodes,
we have a home and student license,
$249
a year. Go buy that. We give you
15 nodes. You can do everything you want.
So, you know, for those of us who
like to tinker at home, myself included,
go go and use Portainer business in your
home setting, learn about all of its its
rich capabilities. You'll love it. And if you're
more than five nodes, it's relatively inexpensive
to get a 15 node environment.
There's a free trial available if you have
a much larger use case on that, but
it's it's very, very simple and easy to
get going.
Road map, we're looking at things like that
front end form based wizard that we had
there that direct that actually direct deploys. One
of the things we're gonna use we're gonna
do is try and use that front end
form as a YAML generator and then push
the result in YAML to a Git repo
and then later deploy from the Git repo.
So it's gonna be a cluster
context aware YAML generator. So you can actually
use it to generate YAML. That's just quite
interesting. One of things I didn't show you
is we have the ability in Portainer to
actually create
Kubernetes clusters natively from within Portainer. So
you can you can go into environments,
add environment, CAS, and then get put your
credentials for any cloud provider, and we'll spin
you up a CAS cluster.
We're adding support for micro k eights for
on prem there as well.
And that that will also transition to be
more as code based.
So, yeah, there's there's a a lot of
lot of stuff coming for Portainer, but we're
we're really focused on making it super easy
to to use. So, yeah, everything we do,
you know, the the the the the number
one rule in in our product team is
can we make it easier? And if the
answer is yes, then we we we keep
iterating our our product ideas until we can
make it easier.
Awesome.
Well, that's a pretty solid road map. I'm
excited to see all those things coming soon.
And I'll say thank you again for joining
me. It's been an absolute pleasure. And hopefully,
we'll do another one of these again soon.
Thank you very much, Neil. All good. Appreciate
it. Thank
you all for watching. Have a great day,
and we'll see you next time. Bye. See
you.